とまず
機械の端いたプレートある
ていました
声かけてもらったという
うれしくって
今ちょっと忙しい時期でもあるのですけれども
お待たないと皆さんのために
提案出来ることがあれば協力したいなと思うので
参加させて
あげたところなんです
冷凍
何をしてほしかったのか聞いてみたところ結構漠然とした体もいただいては先生が車で
行きたいことを調べてくださいんだよ
感じで言われたんですね
そしたら大変なことになるぞ普通の授業の雑か乱れなっちゃうし
最終的には河童の卒塔婆やって言えばをもらったので
自分が考えてお話したい張ってもないよっ
に出るかなっていうことだ
最初に思われます
今回いろいろ可能ないって言う
何を伝えようかなって思った結果こういうタイトルにしました
を紹介する今回の社会ません
てどう
このことを非常になじみのある言葉なんですけどモデルって見たことあるか
順番生徒だったぜってー知ってるはずなんです
そうですね線店長ですね生手順書いてありますね
生物ちょうどこのくだりに書かれているかと言うと
被験者の精神呼ばれている場所に書かれているもうものなんですね
今私たちが乗っ
私たちの聖光学院と4で勉強していると思いますがこのままの法律じゃなくてシリーズ
new
学校なんですね市立っていうのは常に学校店の中でそれでもカップを建てようと思って
出来ていれば
ですから相手を目的とバロー
学校作る
ために
同県っていう方が9作りませんよお金もかかりますし
動画方がいいって何のために作られたのかっていうのが端的に書かれているのかと思う
建学の精神でも
ここでまたこの学校にも私立だったら必ずあるんです
会社だったら大
創設した人間とかする経営年とかって言われているところ
入ってもらえればいいかなって思うんですけれども持ちの彼の拳あったら先生が
もう作っ
3位何を目的としたとしたいのかっていうのがまとめられているのが
建学の精神って所に停められたメッセージになって誘惑してもいいなやっぱすごい
を選んでください
えととピートビッグとしてまとめられるのが
町
5つの要素に分解できるということ
一つ目の端リング的世界観にのおっ
二つ目は人類普遍の価値を尊重する人格の形成
合わせて褒賞活用のある社会の洗顔育成する
pointer 5つの要素に分解する言葉で
ですがあっ
おちゃんはお花はご存知の通りキリスト教的世界観にも取った学校なのでは単純に言う
とこの一番で目指してほしいこと何か持っていると
まあいうものを大切にしていく
他社的なた者志向型の
価値観というもの
尊さ大切さというものをまず理解していただきたい
自己ホームインではなくて他人のために何か役に立つという動機をもって人間として
育っていってほしいというのはこの丸い一番を込められている
ないようになるわけですね
二つ目はちょっとトップしまう
知識がないとわからないかもしれないんですけどいい者で当時勝つとされている3つの
要素
インクアップしていて嬉しいん
全然学の前もそして1周のみ美しさですねこれが人類の中で特に大切されている三陽
沿ってもらっているもので成功月日もうその3つの要素を大切にできるような人になっ
てほしいなっていうのを教育のながら育っていきたいといういいいいとカメラロ
言わない
ねこれ伝統的な感じを思う
この2つのでは個人的には結構腑に落ちている
まあどちらがこの構成にもらっているかなーって思うんですけど
3番目だ綺麗な抽象的で
うんわかりづらいんですね神章嘉津雄のっていうのが入って何をさせているの
食欲はあるん
編ということでちょっと事情的に調べてみたんですけど交渉っていうのは知性品性の
ゲイルは誰がある
気高くてニッパなことですもさまで隊員は継続です
いう脳と体も辞書て君を才能あるん
堆肥は6魔法です
だから
じゃなくて右脳じゃない人になってほしい
言われすることらしいんですけれども継続じゃなくて無料じゃない人ってどんな人なの
だって
ということでこういったと言い方ができるの褒賞発程度なら者から1000位まで通り
全部使うことを指しているの
格好の外へ行っている割には
僕らの中には起爆田中学校
ビューラー人にイメージそういうのが
どうもあると思うんですね
ちょっと前抱いてき2
昔ので考え方にはいい大学ができる人とか
何でも知っている人というのはこれに該当するようにん
思えてしまいますし結局のところ6年間がんばって勉強して大学に進学して
でいいところにね
住みたいそしてそこで勉強していきたいって考え方で僕らの中のが地下にどうも絶対
あると思うんですね
そういうふうに考えた時にいいっちゃいい交渉で有能な人っていうのはすぐにいい
だろう
でた人の好投を指しているのかあるいは何かいろんなものを知ってる人
頑張っているとちょっと違うんじゃないのかなっていうのは個人的な意見です
昔はもしかしたらそういう人が望まれていたのかもしれないんですけれども
今も時代が変わってきたんじゃないかと
思います
この問いかけを考える上で私にしたんですけれども
社会における役割が果たせる人がこの人物に当たると思うので
現代社会はいったいどういう社会だの買っても分析することによって
この人物像っていうのがイメージできるかなーと思いました
ということでイラストやのイラストちょっとか
借りてきたんですけれども
現在社会の級の大きい要素にグローバル社会ということと
っていうのが挙げられるかなぁと思います僕たちはこの社会の中で生きているんですね
昔と比べて世界がより身近になっていき
そして全市域というものを使うことによって
まったくこれまで設定を持たなかった人たちと交流することができるようになる
twitter とかもそうですよね
有名人の人のフォローして
コメントとかしたら彼が返信してくれたらいいんだよね
こと
みんなの中でも経験あるかなぁと思いますこれは絶対設定を持ってなかっている人たち
と関わることができるこの社会の中で僕たちはこれから生きていかなきゃいけないと
いうことです
この社会で活躍するために良い大学に出ているとかあるいは非常に複雑な知識を
併せ持っていることだけが
いうのってを得る
要素なのかという事ですよ個人的にはちょっと違うんじゃないかと思っています
この社会の中で活躍できる人を今もと
ですがたくさん入っておりちょっと
これまでの考え方がちょっと価値観を変えていかないといけないんじゃないかなという
ことです
じゃあこの社会の中で活躍できる人物が持っているべき素養っていったいな
持つ的素養キャラなくなのかという
今は2つの社会65像を示したので1つずつ分解していくと
グローバー社会の一員としては
様々な価値観を理解する力
これは今問われているんじゃないかな
もちろん知識っていうのが必要なんですけどその知識をどうやってに貸すのかの方が
いま重要視されているということ
この価値観を理解することができずににもの者がいることはほぼできないん
ということです
更に言うと高度情報化クレイ情報化社会の中で私たちが必要な素養って何かというと
雑貨等女王自分の中で
貸借してそして正しいいうものを選択していく力
これが今必要不可欠な力として挙げられるものなんじゃないかなと思います
先ほどもいってる知識は前提なんですその知識をどのようにして自分が判断していくの
か
この判断力っていうのが
今必要になってきていることなのかなぁと思います
昔はまあ funfun 順に一民族の中で活動していた時代から今変わってきていて
その多くの価値観の中で私たちは自分らしさというものを見つけていかなきゃいけない
わけですし
かつその人たちが生きて行く場所を私たちは受け指摘
ん
否定しちゃいけないと思うんですよ受けいかなきゃいけないわけです
そのために必要な力がまあここに関わってくると思うんですが
じゃあこれを育てるためにはどうすればいいのかというとですね今言ったように最低
条件としてホイ先入観連研常識っていうもの一旦疑うようなそういった力が必要なん
じゃない
だということです
ではそれを曲げている交渉かついうのが社会の戦へ帰省するっていうのを目指している
今後をその力を手にするための教育活動っていうのを目指してい
べきだと思うんですけどそれっ
どういう活動をしたら手に入るのかということです
単純に問題集と言っていい
後ろの回答を移して中丸を付けして
といいだけ続けていたらそういう影響の仕方をしていて
話の力が身につくのかあっ
帳尻合わせる近くに着くと
ですよね今そういうものは必要ないんだっていうことで
人間性結果になるとは思いますけど
僕たちがそこで活躍する人間はそろっ
細したい隠蔽したりするような家から育てる僕じゃないんじゃないかなと
ということです
この力を育てることは基準難しいです
これあの頃に傘やのかわいい出すと思う
当館のあげようと考えたんですが胃の中の蛙ですね私たちがお
気張りギターと価値観の中で閉じこもって上空に見える空だけが自分の世界観だつまり
いい大学に行けばいいとか良い就職先にいやそれでいいみたいなそういった混乱
ガーターを振っこうしてなきゃいけないわけです
油い政治家みたら次になります
移動から脱出するためにらに彼が必要だということです
それで何が必要なのかっていうのを
まず最初にしなきゃいけないことはこれ最低証券ですが自分が井戸に今いるんだという
ことをそもそも知らないから
井戸から外に出て行くことができないわけです
ブーブー言うとして持ったんですけど
ルマティ
と言う
バカが書いた人間の条件って言えるです
この手が8
を示して説明したい内容っていうのが何かちょっと分かります
考えてもらいたいんですけどどういう家のかっていうと
風景画のように入れるんですけれども窓の前にキャンパスが置かれていてその
キャンパスに1
おそらくマーカーの外と同じ女ある景色が映ってるんですけど
この絵をかいたままグリーンという人は行って何を僕たちに伝えたかったのか
考えていたん
不思議な絵ですよ
僕たちはこれを見たときになんとなく兄子宮の中で
ああ
このキャンパスの中に開かれている大きなん貴女
おそらくまずの外に
あるんだなぁてくる認識をすると思うんです
押せそうじゃなかったらこんなへの福利ランいるわけですからね
これいったい何を指しているのかというと僕たちの物の見方っていうのがこの
キャンパスを通して見ている方に非常に居てるんじゃないかっていうのを示している
ものです
2陣営とどういうことかというと例えば
キャンパスの輪郭は苦戦全部外して見てもらったらわかりますよね
そして見ている景色と思うんだとになってしまう
私達っていうのをキャンパスってフィルター越しにも見ている
そうでしかも認識することができないということを
ラブリーにとってきたら説明しようとしているんじゃないかと言う
具体的にところです
これは関東の良い式コペルニクス的転回食べてる物の見方なんですか
色いる
今もってごまいくとかあとここにあるパソコンとか
僕じゃない何が対象物いるのが自分ダン独立して存在していると思いますよね
つまり自分が神殿をここにあるパ側もさまざま存在し続けるしうちの放射もこの学校を
ジュっぽくな診断をそこにあり続けるんだって言う子式をよくた地域ニョクリッするっ
て思っん
でも本当にそうなのかそれを障害することってできるのかなということです
できないんですなぜかというと私たちは必ず自分っていうものを通してでしかものを
認識するとかできないからです
つまりいい
さっきにてもらうのだこの
キャンパスを通してれっしかこれメールフィルターだと思っ
私たちはこのソードっていう認識することってはできないんですよ
polling いる光景ですよ私たちの主観って絵を書いてある
偽物か本物か分からない状況でしかファンができないっていうことを示しているわけ
ですか
これを気づいか時に何ができるかというと僕たちがこれまで正しいとか若干的であった
かって思っていることが実は主観の総体であるってことがなんだって理解することが
できるようになってくる
つまり価値観が変わるんです物の見方が変わってくる
これまでの一般常識的なとらえ方では桜を
至る事の出来なかった気づきとかマッケンとか不思議だなあとか
じゃあ月どういうことを考えられていけないのかとかは私たちのもの違う目線を与える
ことによってお酒兼業できるんじゃないかなということです
私たちがこの前提に立って考えていくと感じる日ですね正しい
っていうふうに結論付けることは危険なんじゃないかなっていう
ことがわかると思うんですね法律で決まってるから正しいと思う
科学の桜そっくり決まってるか合っているんだ
に生きていったんストップして本当に正しい el のかアティロンてくるじゃないか
なということですちょい here are 新調しツアーしとって考える言っにわー
w
次必要ナンバーは鉄アガラじゃないかって言う
ことです中3の事業カレーパン哲学
おい話すこれは
としてきたんで今
ブーブレてるんじゃないかと信じてるんですけど
ブーブーぼくなつ買うことによっにょ一度ぞ
冷静にさせるてそこから教育というものを再構築していく必要ってのがあるんじゃない
かなと思います
もちろん知識が必要なので現在行われているような授業っていうのは派ならず
君たちにとって非常に役に立つものかなぁとも思うんですけども
それにプラスアルファーして辛くしても別に住んじゃないんだ
いいじゃん別にどっちかしかなくちゃいけないなっている line だとかどっちを
買ったほうがと水ラーメンだからツインてサーブもやっちゃうよ
大涅槃きてあのー僕は提案したいかなということで空けてもらうのであのん
アップに必要なもとっては別だとくる感じ
高所活用の味が入らせい
多いんで哲学的な眼差しを持ってるかどうかっていうのは一段階レベルは変わってくる
授業メロスはじゃないかなと
ことですね
すいません長くなってしまいましたがこれでおります
ありがとうございます